هذه قال رئيس منظمه الطاقه الذريه
الايرانيه محمد اسلامي ان نسبه تخصيب
مخزون بلاده من اليورانيوم لا تتجاوز 60
في المئه وفيما يخص المواقع الثلاثه التي
طلبت الوكاله الوصول اليها وعثرت على اثار
لليورانيوم فيها قال اسلامي ان المحادثات
مع الوكاله ستستمر بهدف الوصول الى تسويه
بشانها
اذا راجعتم تقرير السيد جروسي الاخيس
ستجدون انه يطرح موضوع الكشف عن الجزيئات
من اليورانيوم بنسبه
84% ولا يتحدث عن تخصيب اليورانيوم بنسبه
84% والتحقيقات اثبتت ان مخزون ايران من
اليورانيوم المخصب لا يتجاوز نسبه 60%
لهذا السبب ليس هناك ما يستدعي التركيز
على هذه النقاط ويمكن القول انها سويت
نوعا ما فيما يخص المواقع الثلاثه وصلنا
مع السيد غروسي الى اطار عمل مشترك خلال
زياره السابقه الى فيينا وسنواصل العمل في
الاطار نفسه والمحادثات ستستمر في هذا
الشان والتعامل بين طهران والوكاله
الدوليه متواصل بهدف تسويه هذه النقاط
كما حذر رئيس منظمه طاقه الذريه الايرانيه
من ان بلاده سترد على اي قرار قد يصدر
ضدها في الاجتماع المقبل لمجلس محافظي
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه مشيرا الى
ان هناك من يسعى الى تخريب العلاقات بين
طهران والوكاله وفق تعبير
زياره مدير الوكاله الى طهران تؤكد وجود
علاقات محترفه بين طهران والوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه ونامل ان تؤدي هذه العلاقات
الى بناء الثقه وان نكون قادرين على حل
وتسويه الملفات العالقه بعيدا عن
التسريبات والتدخلات الاجنبيه التي تنوي
تخريب العلاقه بين طهران والوكاله نريد ان
تستمر علاقاتنا مع الوكاله حتى تتمكن من
اداء واجباتها بشان البرنامج النووي
الايراني في اطار اتفاق الضمانات الشامله
نؤكد على ضروره الابتعاد عن المسائل التي
من شانها تخريب العلاقات المشتركه بين
طهران والوكاله وسنرد على اي قرار قد يسطر
ضدنا في اجتماع مجلس محافظي الوكاله